[Music]
foreign
a first look at what is on the front
pages time then to see what's making the
headlines with HuffPost UK's political
editor Kevin Schofield and the
telegraph's assistant comment editor
Madeleine Grant great to see both of you
so let's see uh which of the newspapers
are covering the latest news on Sir
Gavin Williamson certainly the eye does
leading with the resignation of sagavin
over allegations of bullying and reports
claims that there were concerns that he
couldn't be trusted with National
Security matters here is the mail the
headline Williamson forced out in cut
your throat bully row
likewise the times Williamson quits amid
new claims of bullying the guardian
quotes one of his former deputies as a
chief whip calling him unethical and
immoral the Metro contrast Matt
Hancock's entry into I'm a celebrity
with sir Gavin's exit from the
government the star remarks on the
challenges Mr Hancock can expect to face
in the jungle while the mirror expects
his fellow contestants will quiz him on
his handling of the covid crisis the
express says its readers have played a
part in apparently ensuring the
pension's triple lock pledge isn't
dropped from the Chancellor's upcoming
Autumn statement and the financial times
reporting on what it calls the near
collapse of the cryptocurrency firm FTX
all reminded by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages
Optimus newspapers while you watch us
but let's get the thoughts now of Kevin
Schofield and Madeleine Grant just two
papers outliers there in the story of
two MPS tonight Madeleine so let's pick
up shall we honor Mr or sorry sir sir
Gavin Williamson who's decided to quit
uh your thoughts
yes
um he's quit and after he said that um
his presence in around the cabinet table
was becoming too much of a distraction
um but I think it was becoming too much
of a political headache for Rishi sunak
to maintain his position there given the
outcry from many different sides of of
the Tory party over the alleged behavior
and in fact there was a great deal of
bitterness and resentment left over from
other wings of the party from the summer
race where Gavin Williamson was helping
to manage Rishi sunax leadership contest
and I spoke to I've spoken to quite a
few MPS who report being very unhappy
with some of the kind of traditional
dark arts that were being deployed then
um as they were deployed famously when
Gavin Williamson served as Chief whip
during the Theresa May years
um and it puts Richie snow I think in in
a quite a difficult place because now
you get he's been forced to make an
enemy of of Gavin Williamson who is in
you know someone that you would probably
want to have in the tent rather than out
of it as well as taking all of the
political heat from having hired him in
the first place but without any of the
upside and it's I think reminiscent
despite the fact that Rishi sunak is
trying to break away from that feeling
of of chaos and uncertainty that hung
around Boris Johnson's time in office
but it was that scenario that became
very familiar during the Boris Johnson
days when the reverse ferret would
generally happen but sort of quite late
in the day late enough to get all of the
annoyance but uh but not soon enough to
get any of the credit for having acted
well yeah I mean it's extraordinary
isn't it that Mrs Unix only actually
been in office for two weeks you know
who'd have thought it it's been quite
turbulent hasn't it this period of
political calm that everyone was looking
forward to but this idea of sargavin you
know needing to be in the tent is he
really that influential Kevin or that
dangerous
potentially although I think now that
he's
um life government for the third time if
you remember he was sacked as defense
secretary was sacked as education
secretary and I was resigned this
evening I just wonder whether
um we might overstate a little bit his
his importance now
um he's more a figure of fun I think as
much as anything
um I mean it's true what Madeleine says
you know he has a perpetrator of the
dark arts and he is someone obviously
who wishes tonight depended on quite
heavily uh in both leadership contests
this year and which is why he gave him
the job that he did
um however I think now he's so tainted
uh and we might yet see more Revelations
to come and certainly these
investigations that are going on if they
find against him then I think his
political career is well and truly over
if it isn't already so um yeah it is
embarrassing for Rishi Suna absolutely
no doubt about it he stood on the steps
of number 10 two weeks ago talking about
professionalism and integrity is
essentially trying to draw a line under
the chaotic tenures of Boris Johnson and
Liz truss and as you see here we are two
weeks later he's already lost a minister
and serious questions now about his
judgment you know he was made aware of
the um the complaint
um the initial complaint against Gavin
Williamson before he brought him into
government he went ahead and gave him a
job anyway and it's come back to bite
him so uh yeah I think he's in for quite
a rough ride tomorrow uh at Prime
Minister's questions
Stanley Street suggesting they knew of
the generalities of this complaint but
not the specifics I guess but yes more
allegations to come well what's the eye
saying tonight Madeleine suggestions
that UK intelligence officials had
accused him of becoming a risk to
National Security
um his new cabinet job gave him
oversight of UK security issues despite
Williamson being sacked as defense
secretary back in 2019 for allegedly
leaking highly sensitive information
which um he denied of course
well precisely I mean I think I think
you've said it that that is what they're
reporting I don't know any more detail
about that story because I don't think
I've had access to it yet but this was
something that Gavin Williamson was kind
of known for around Westminster for
being quite leak prone
um so you can imagine that although
Minister without portfolio was not um
perhaps the most uh key job in cabinet
um if there was there were to be
situations where he was looking at
highly sensitive information that that
might have rung a few alarm Bells
foreign
and the newspapers many of them quoting
the uh interview tonight done by his
former deputy and Milton suggesting he
was unethical about the threats you know
how serious is it when it comes from
somebody who worked alongside him in
that way Kevin
well yeah I mean it's it's an authentic
from the horse's mouth eyewitness
account really of someone who who saw
um Gavin Williamson up close how he
operated on a day-to-day basis and it's
quite a remarkable interview she talks
about how
um he loved uh salacious gossip how he'd
come into the office and talk about the
um various embarrassing
um aspects of MP's uh personal lives and
then there was one occasion according to
Anne Milton where 1np was in a bit of
financial difficulty so the the party
stepped in to help him
um with a check which Anne Milton was to
give to the MP in question and Governor
Williamson upon I said to you know just
make sure that he knows that I now own
him and now she says that he will
probably say he was joking but she says
as far as I'm concerned he definitely
was not joking so I think that gives an
insight into maybe the character of
Gavin Williamson and um yeah as I say I
think you know the longer this went on
without some sort of
um end to it uh with him leaving
government I think there might have been
more
um Revelations to come you'd obviously
made a lot of enemies during his time
both as Chief Whip and then his other
government roles and I think it was it
was payback time for a lot of MPS I
think they could see that he was on the
ropes and this was their opportunity to
um settle some old scores so uh so yeah
I think as I say again it just comes
back to Rishi sunak's judgment really he
chose to bring him into government and
there was always a risk given how
divisive a character Gavin mountain is
there's always a risk that it might end
badly I don't think anyone expected it
to end quite as quickly as it has but um
but yeah it has and this isn't what
we're hoping that that sort of draws a
line under and he can perhaps move on
but I do think that um that it's not the
last that we've heard of this of this
story yes and certainly the times uh
brings in the prospect of uh you know
there's new bullying claims as well um
Madeleine but you know for somebody
who's only been in office for for 14
days you know they've been difficulties
haven't their real questions over his
appointment as well a bravaman who
herself had only just resigned why was
the Gavin Williamson back there why did
he think going to cop was a good idea
and now of course he has to land the
nation with with what tax increases and
public spending cuts I mean you we're
looking at another Torrid 30 days of a
prime minister aren't we
I think it was uh given all the above it
was it was never going to be a a Halcyon
period for for any prime minister but
and uh but I do think that that's right
that things seem to have become pretty
wobbly pretty quickly
um and actually that there was I think
an initial feeling of
um General support for sunac within the
party because MPS appreciated that this
was the intro from hell but all of that
has been very quickly overtaken
um by events and we're already getting
to the stage now where there is acrimony
from different sides of the party some
of the problem I think was the kind of
um the the tactics that Rishi sunak had
to employ in order to win in the first
place to have someone like Gavin
Williamson on side who you know uses
whipping of the kind that may maybe it's
not alien to British politics by any
stretch but it feels like the kind of
bruised performative Bruiser tactics
that are more reminiscent of you know a
few administrations ago perhaps
um and also cracking a deal with Sue
Ella Braven to bring the right of more
of the right of the party with her and
so some chickens are coming home to
roost and all of this is going against
the backdrop of um the uh the Autumn
statement next week and all of the
likely uh possible tax increases and
other things that are going to be very
unpopular with um Tory MPS and
um yet more acrimony and yet more
controversy beckons I think
remembers too I think the Daily Mail on
their front page suggesting that Rishi
may bring back the 50p tax rate which
was you know almost the opposite of what
we saw from uh that Liz trust mini
budget was it not but um the Metro also
um you know going in more detail about
some of the allegations against
um sir Gavin Williamson one Tory MP
suggesting he knows uh where the
skeleton's about he's given me a few
sleepless nights politics is about being
tough and pushing people to do what you
want but this is on another level I mean
what it is said about somebody who's
been a chief web do they just continue
to live the role and enact the dark arts
at every opportunity Kevin
hmm
I don't think they're all like that I
mean they all have different ways of
doing the job I think Gavin Rosen was a
pretty unique character you know you
mentioned the performative element I
think that there was a bit of that I
think he enjoyed this reputation that he
had for being this Machiavellian figure
in famously had his pet tarantula Cronus
in a glass box on his desk as a way of
threatening uh recalcitrant MPS you know
it's all a bit cliched really so I think
Gavin Williamson as Madeline says was a
bit of a throwback to the days when
um Chief whips would uh use all sorts of
Nefarious tactics to to get MPS to bend
to their will I think you know they're
not all like that these days but he
certainly did earn a reputation and you
know I spoke to one conservative a
couple of days ago who said they would
not go public with any criticism of them
because they were frightened basically
of what you do to them in return so I
mean it's quite you know incredible to
hear that so
um he did have a reputation and it seems
that he did obviously threaten quite a
few people and there will be a lot of
conservative MPS this evening will be
relishing the fact that in their view
he's getting his his comeuppance really
uh with this latest Fall From Grace
well talking of creepy crawlies
um and giant spiders in fact two we move
on after the break from one politician
who reportedly used those people callers
to get his way to another who really
doesn't like them we'll look at Matt
Hancock's entry into the I'm a celebrity
jungle that's next
[Music]
thank you
watching The Press preview With Me Now
Kevin Schofield and Madeleine girl
welcome back to both of you so we move
on to another politician would you
believe Kevin uh the Metro he's in and
he's out helpfully annotating the two
politicians we've been talking about
this evening It's a Jungle Out There is
it not and the Daily Mirror speculating
that actually
um the celebs will tackle him on covid
um I mean what what will he be facing do
you reckon
although I mean that that's the thing I
mean Matt Hancock's official reason for
taking this uh decision is that he wants
to get in there and and communicate
directly with uh voters because the what
I'm a celebrity and able to give an
opportunity to talk about things like
dyslexia which is one of the issues
which he has campaigned on the problem
is though he has got absolutely no
control over what his campmates want to
speak to him about no matter are saying
that they want to they might want to
pick him up on his um performance as
health secretary during the pandemic uh
and maybe criticism of some of the
decisions that he and the government
took at the time so it could be a deeply
not not at least because you it may
you're probably made to eat
unmentionable parts of um animals bodies
but um but he'll also be put on the spot
by his Camp it's as I say to explain
himself and his decisions during the
pandemic so um if he thinks he's going
to be getting an easy ride in there or
it's an opportunity to relaunch himself
and reinvent himself then I think he
might be in for about waiting well
Martin we've run out of time would you
believe it do apologize Daily Star fears
of a clown uh revealed that he's
petrified of all snakes and uh the end
of their first paragraph just says this
could be fun well we will see shall we
um both of you uh it's been fun thank
you both very much indeed